hello 735 oh it's you those you fat
bastard
what the [ __ ] do you want I'm coming to
pick up where dr. Montgomery left off of
you that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't be having fun in that cell prick
you want to go join MC again [ __ ] his
[ __ ] no I'm here to talk about you
tonight
oh yeah [ __ ] for brains what about the
fact that Montgomery's been screwing
your wife for the past two months that's
not true and you know it
anyway as I said I'm here to talk about
you not me yeah you're right like how
you couldn't get it up last night even
though that fat [ __ ] was pounding your
ass with a dildo while that gay Swedish
hardcore porn was on huh see I knew you
were [ __ ] [ __ ] all right now you
know that's really uncalled for
you mean like that stink that's coming
of you good the one D at 3000 our wife
is fooling around you look and smell
like a [ __ ] rotting Buffalo you know
she has her tongue in montgomery's ass
right now she loves doing that she'd
never do it to you though you hairy
bloated [ __ ] but that's okay
you like getting that for a man anyway
shut up shut up I can't help it I work
in this hole all day just to afford that
house maybe by I can't help it if I
never have time to go to the gym you
miserable [ __ ] you haven't seen your
dick in five years anyway it's too late
for the gym and you're still not making
enough money to satisfy that [ __ ]
that's why Montgomery bought your Dyke
wife that new blouse last week he said
it was on sale she would she's a [ __ ]
liar and you are a pathetic [ __ ]
[ __ ] the believer you piece of [ __ ] you
take that back like you took
car you but just because the [ __ ]
wife made you Jesus she's got the whip
wrapped around your neck [ __ ] [ __ ]
pilot said you [ __ ]